-Our next guest
is a Grammy Award-winning
country music superstar.
Her latest album, "My Gift,"
is available now,
And her holiday special,
"My Gift:
A Christmas Special
from Carrie Underwood,"
is currently streaming
on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-♪♪ Pretty little wishes
tied up in a bow ♪♪
♪♪ And every little kiss is li
we're underneath the mistletoe ♪
♪♪ It's music to my ears ♪♪
♪♪ Christmas is my
favorite time of year ♪♪
-♪♪ Christmas
is my favorite time ♪♪
-♪♪ Christmas is my
favorite time of year ♪♪
-Please welcome back
to the show Carrie Underwood
How are you, Carrie?
-Hi. I'm good. How are you
-I'm good.
It's been a very long time
The last time we crossed paths
six years ago, you were here
with our friend Brad Paisley
-It's been too long.
Been too long.
-You've recorded a lot of
Christmas songs over the years
This is the first time
you've done a full album.
I imagine this is a mileston
of sorts for any music artist.
-Yeah. I mean, I feel like i
you have a decently long career,
it's probably
somewhat inevitable
you'll do something like this.
It's always been
on my musical bucket list.
But this year just seemed like
the perfect year to do it.
I mean, it seemed like
the perfect year
before 2020 became
what it became.
But especially
in the midst of it,
it was just nice to be abl
to create positive --
positive music and put positive,
happy, peaceful, joyful vibe
into the world.
-I do think because, you know,
it's such a family holiday
I think we like when we hear
Christmas songs
from people we already know.
Another thing that's
the case for me with you
is I feel great warmth
and comfort
when you sing the
"Sunday Night Football" song
And I'm so happy
that football is back.
And I'm wondering,
do you ever watch the games?
Do you ever
see yourself introduce
the Sunday night slate?
-I do.
It is comforting to have those
things that you can count on
like holidays,
like "Sunday Night Football.
It's been so much fun
being able to do the open,
and we do watch football
as much as we can.
I do have two small children
who kind of take over
the television occasionally,
so we don't always get to watc
what we want,
but we watch as much footbal
as we can.
And it was so much fun.
Actually not too long ago, w
were all sitting on the couch,
and the open came on,
and my 5-year-old was like
"That's you.
Are you in the show?"
And I was like,
"No, I'm not in the show.
I just introduce,
you know, the game."
It was hard for him to grasp why
I was singing about football
-I wonder about this.
We have a photo of you
and your son.
Isaiah is your older son?
-Yes, yeah.
-And he actually
appears in your special.
You got him to sing one of
the Christmas songs with you
Was he enthusiastic about this
-He was. He loves music.
He loves to sing.
I asked him.
You know, I didn't want
to force him to do anything.
I was like -- I don't know
what we're going to get
out of this day,
but if nothing else,
he just came to work with me
gets to see what I do.
But he did such a great job.
He showed up,
like, ready to work,
and he was just
throwing his hands in the air.
And it was such a magical da
for me just as a mom
getting to share
what I love with him.
He did such a great job.
-I would imagine --
My kids are great.
I got a 4 1/2-year-old.
I would give him
about 30 minutes
before he was not providin
anything of use.
How long did Isaiah provid
high-quality work for you?
-He did a pretty good job.
I could see
towards the end, his --
You know, it's like,
"I saw drums in the other room
and I really want
to go play those
instead of being in here
singing with you."
But we got enough, and he --
I think he would have come bac
later if we needed him to,
but we did not.
-That's great.
I'm very impressed
with something you did.
You know, every year,
I ask my wife,
"Is there something
you want for Christmas?"
She says either, "Don't get me
anything or whatever you think."
I'm very impressed.
You told your husband
what you wanted for Christmas,
and he came through, correct
-Yes, he did.
-And what did you want?
-I wanted cows.
I grew up with cows,
and I love them.
They're like big dogs to me.
They're probably my favorite
animal if I had to pick one.
And I've always wanted them.
So when he said, "What
do you want for Christmas?
"Cows. Get me two,
just, pet, useless cows."
-Now, I will admit that
if Alexi asked me to do that
I would not have any sense
of what the next step is
to buy cows.
How quickly did your husband
manage to procure the cows
-He slapped some wranglers o
and put his hat on,
and he was at the sale,
like, two days later.
He was like, "I didn't kno
what was happening."
The guy was talking real fast.
He was an auctioneer.
And he said,
"I don't know what happened.
I think we got females.
I'm not sure."
But we just raised our
little paddle a couple times
and next thing you know,
they're loading up two cow
to bring home.
They were -- They're ladies.
Mm-hmm.
-I would imagine this outcom
for cows at auction
is about as good as you can do
to end up in Carrie Underwood'
backyard as opposed to
where else you could be.
-That's why I wanted them.
He was like,
"Where does one get cows?"
And I was like,
"There's auctions all the time."
I said, "Go get some."
If it looks like it would make
a good burger some day,
bring her home.
-Well, that is
a Christmas miracle.
-I feel like I need to say that.
She will -- They will never be
They are just pets.
-They're just looking-at cows.
You're very lucky to have those.
We're very lucky to have you
and thank you so much
for sticking around
and doing a song for us.
We really appreciate it.
-Thank you, yeah.